all right andrew take the intro away
what is going on there reject nation i
don't remember the right
that's all that needs to be said man
roll the intro
guys greg and john are joined by andrew
gordon of the movie source channel to
check out cobra guys season 4 episode 6
kicks get chicks
rhymes
get
subscriptions hit that notification bell
and hey hit the like button if you enjoy
our reactions to cobra kai because
there's more on the way also hey if you
want to see the full thing sync up with
your own copy come on over to our
patreon page become a superject today
we've got tons of shows over there you
can either sync up with or check out the
reaction highlights for and last but
certainly not least prepper the team
over there they make these possible so
give them some love and hey
let's actually roll the intro now
that was good andrew she killed it dude
i thought i was missing something in
there but
i had done it
[Music]
enough of this [ __ ] oh it might be
[ __ ] to you but some of us here
actually care about tradition oh don't
go there again george clearly the blue
mats led to a surge in attendance why
would we go back to the red man
oh god
in young female interest we need to
speak to that audience but instead of
karate we put on a baking class it's a
wonder you've been divorced three times
george
george what about a grand marshal or a
musical performance you know one of the
dads on my son's fencing team he's a
talent agent oh god roger's the musical
i would go through the proper channels
this time
you couldn't get louie anderson to show
up for a free buffet ron you're out of
order daryl you're not a judge wrong why
do i have this gavel not anymore
damn that's some great camera work you
guys got we're sanctioning an event
where boys are encouraged to kick and
punch girls
have any of you thought for a moment
this could be perceived as
problematic
actually it would be less problematic if
everyone could just hit everyone this
proposal will revolutionize the
tournament this is our legacy by a show
of hands
do we all agree on the changes
the hell are the changes the matte color
send out the letters
god help us all
[Music]
i have to be in yellow
there'll be two all valley champs
wait so what does that mean for the bet
with cobra kai there's a grand champion
trophy for whichever dojo wins the most
points all i know is the girls division
is mine
well that just leaves the skills and the
boys oh my god tori versus him but it's
time to put the past behind us all right
don't worry by the time the tournament
comes around you're gonna realize that
this was the best thing that could have
happened to us
this is the worst thing that could have
happened to us skills competition
[ __ ] code isn't karate it's dancing
what's this crap about a girls division
i thought they're all about women's lib
sensei it sounds like we could use some
female students
fine get ayesha back
do any of you know any girls
come on yasmin moon and of course you
don't know any girl
all right go around some laps maybe
it'll jog your memories
you shouldn't have to breathe too much
some black mold in the corner
turn that into a lesson i want our logo
on billboards t-shirts and on the backs
of both old valley champions now we're
talking
damn
sick who do you think's gonna win a
custody battle huh you're a high school
dropout and a criminal so are you yeah
but i know how to play the game
a judge is gonna take one look at you
and laugh you straight out of court you
look like a drug addict yeah
yeah she needs that money for meth
please when i went to this school the
only thing i was better at than karate
and i was pretty good at karate was
talking to chicks
watching lord diaz watch and learn
no
got to be under 18 or it's a no-go
[Music]
hey stop it johnny yes this is the way
trust me the chicks are gonna love this
do it come on you gotta get into every
groove
it's about molding highlights to
emphasize curvature
we have a whole stable of hot young
dudes like my man miguel over here
uh
i'm asexual
all right he's a sexual too check him
out
so what do you say you ready to become
an eagle
who beat eagle baby apparently some perv
is creeping on the track team so we're
gonna practice inside what are you guys
doing here
i can't do the whole physical aggression
thing
you know i should ask my ex hawk yeah
nobody piper the other ex
she's the best athlete in school and
she's not afraid to get into a fight
she has rage issues you might want to
take a different approach with her
you want some pointers
absolutely
her ex was amanda
corey
mrs russo i need your help talk to a
therapist a guidance counselor the dalai
lama it doesn't matter just someone who
isn't
karate related
whatever it takes i'll do it
oh samson and you're gonna be fighting
against lots of new opponents and what
what the hell is she doing here
i'm gonna take everything i said
i'm gonna kill your daughter
how do you even get in here
your mom has left the key under the
flower gnome since kindergarten you
should really think about increasing
insecurity given you know the karate war
[Laughter]
that old thing
i don't care if you have a mohawk or a
mullet or
pigtails
miyagi don't need you i want to see him
in pigtails you can be called pig
i'm done with karate man
i quit
[Laughter]
oh which one is yours
well that one looks good to me
keep it up johnny
remember what moon told you yes i will
be awake
yeah no no no i'll be woke
[Laughter]
up let me tell you why my dojo is a
perfect place for a modern young woman
like yourself we live in a world where
you got to be an alpha to survive you're
either a killer or you're dead meat you
got to be a man
at eagle fang we confront that
problematic phrase and make it
empowering for all we teach anyone who
identifies as female to embrace their
queenly strength and tear down the
neo-masculine hierarchy to confront
internalized sexes
what about non-binary and genderfluid
yes fluids are crucial
i'll be there all right
oh sensei i can't believe you pulled
that off did you even know what any of
those terms meant do i look like a piece
sitting down
[Music]
it depends on the time of day as long as
she is in school she has something to
lose sam she's not going to hurt you
you're just going to believe her so
you'll listen to what she has to say but
nobody's going to listen to what i have
to say
god damn did i ever tell you about the
time i was arrested
she sure what it was a high school prank
and by prank i meant i took a baseball
bat to my math tutor's car um
with her in it
you're a psycho woman
because she was having an affair with my
dad
oh my god
kids like tori they get the same
messages delivered to them over and over
again the same exact way
sometimes they just need a wake-up call
to
change course
he's not the only one who needs a
wake-up call
god damn amanda you married your father
[Laughter]
he's cheating with johnny lauren
i know you think that that mohawk
defined who you are it didn't
not to me
the tattoo does hawk
hell call yourself cornelius from light
care or buzz and a b tattoo whether
you're number one
or zero
that was really sweet
all kinds of sweetness happening bro
bonding terry silver just popped up out
of the blue right
he did the same thing to me
he'll seem decent enough show you a few
moves and then he'll warm his way in
chip away at you
and push you past your lips bloody your
knuckles you'll become stronger than you
thought possible
but silver won't stop there
oh [ __ ]
you were a hothead all i had to do was
wind you up you know you liked it
you were powerful
free
you just don't want to admit there's
always been a little cobra kai in you
hmm yeah that's what i says
and when we win
cobra kai
and you will be out of business one of
us will be
hmm hey man if you're going to use this
place as a conference room you got to
buy something
oh he owns it now doesn't he
tick tick tock
that guy's going to join next week oh no
what
they're all a cobra kai
cobra kai subscription boxes nothing but
the best for the best can't wait to kick
ass with team cobra kai she joined cobra
kai what
looks like they made a bunch of designer
gear for all the new students they got a
bunch of new recruits yeah great
so that was just a big waste of time i
even learned feminism
[Laughter]
hey she's back right i've been waiting
for this
tori wants to come back to west valley
and my parents just want me to be cool
about it we're talking about the same
overprotective larussos who made me wear
a helmet on your trampoline mm-hmm
when i started my new school there was
this girl in my homeroom she knew she
was gonna be my next boy i introduced
myself
i even told her i liked her shoes
seemed like the polite thing to do told
her i was new and i asked her she could
introduce miro how did i go she's my
bestie
my new school bestie you always be the
o.g
i attacked my problem head-on
i struck first
with compassion
my parents moved me here to get me away
from the karate drama it can't stop me
from using the lessons i learned from
sensei lawrence
i set my own terms
set yours there's positive ways to
strike first
i thought debate was for nerds it is
which is why we're ditching it
you're right i'm not giving up on the
girls competition think outside the box
uh i'm gonna see the movie
ladybugs yes
i love that movie so you want me to
dress up like a girl what no i need you
to win the boys competition
they get a penis breath he's not the
best fighter but i think he stands a
decent shot against the chicks what do
you think
his evidence is garbage his arguments
don't make a lick of sense and i was
bored to death which is ironic
considering we're debating the death
penalty
choke on it
i see my time
bam get her job the girl i told you
about and she loves extracurricular
i just found the most badass girl in the
valley
[Applause]
not bad
damn it no no that was great that kick
was awesome
it was
look who decided to come back
[Music]
hell yeah
i'm just here to do what i can to help
out the team
that's good
the more help the better but first you
need a key could have you batman
that speech worked dimitri that was a
really good kick he gave it you and mom
were right
it's time we leave the past behind us
right yeah
i'm proud of you sam
it's never easy being the bigger person
uh i don't i don't like that
we specifically got to check you
[Music]
all right sam be nice to her
i heard you let me back in larissa
so i guess i don't know what kind of
game you're playing
but i'm not scared of you
you're not in control here i am okay oh
but if you so much as look at me funny
i will kick your ass for a third time
[Laughter]
that's exactly how i saw that
conversation go down
oh sheepers
how hard is it to hit a back button jeff
god oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
embarrassing joe
embarrassing stupid stupid stupid
all right andrew how many easter eggs do
you think you'll have uh just a couple
on this one but i have some an
interesting one though
all right
reserve it okay
well the time is right
i'll tell you when i'll strike one time
you will know
the signal will burn bright
all right
what happened
permanent series regular not just a
cameo every episode they're gonna drive
to santa barbara to get some words of
wisdom about how she applied karate in
her life she was sam's therapist now
i thought she was gonna have like a
different way of striking first that
wasn't gonna be as aggressive
but sam went full aggression there yeah
turned to the dark side johnny's taught
her well i mean you know
she i don't blame sam for for being that
way yeah sam i like the light character
i like her but i don't know if she's
liked is there who's like not liked on
this show is there a character who like
fans don't like
i would say probably maybe sam would be
one of them for sure sexist yeah yeah
not very woke of you not very awake of
you man yeah
yeah
stay awake buddy
uh but i do like that character though
tyler everyone's favorite character is
kyle oh yeah definitely i know
this is the kind of thing where i'm like
if sam like when i watch this since i'm
like i'm not sure how much i believe the
toughness from her when she's being all
tough
but then i'm like i know me if she said
that to me to my face i'd be like i'm so
sorry
i'm sorry please
you're terrible terrified yeah
uh yeah that was a that was a surprise
tournament tori's really trying to do
the right it's
funny how they play with that
play with dynamics it's one of the fun
things about writing it's a playground
of characters let's see which swing they
go on this season right
where tori is trying to do some
some nicer things and get her life back
on track and we sympathize for her as
you guys see how [ __ ] her personal life
is it's not just some sob story wow what
else does
what other reason would you need to go
school sucks guys other than it's the
basic foundational building block of
maybe a solid light if you're in school
and you're watching this
i just want you to know
yeah it's boring there isn't it
so boring but it's important so stick
around but it's not the key to
everything stupid
yeah that's uh
danny glover predator too yep exactly
and uh yeah that was a that was that was
an interesting turn of events there
and then this whole thing with
this modern day woke commentary that
they're throwing into my cobra kai
wtf virtue signaling lib politics
all in my face right now
as they are uh looking for the right
woman to encounter but dan that [ __ ] did
look tough yeah
yeah
easter egg number one i really love the
confrontation though because i think
terry's right man there's always been a
little bit of cobra kai in that
hot-headed italian boiled danny larussa
there's always been a little bit of
cobra kind in that's been a big part of
why he's gravitated towards miyagi does
learn how to control his anger because
the duke clearly has a temper and he's
nowhere near where
where miyagi was miyagi was like zen
about everything he was corralling
his cobra guys you mess up my bonsai
tree that i've been growing for decades
he shows up he's like it's okay i
forgive him oh i'll fix it you think
danny would be that way hell no man
so yeah that was uh
that was uh that was a good scene good
encounter and i wonder what robbie's
gonna do andrew unleash the reference
uh so what i noticed
um the one one of them was when during
the scene you just mentioned with daniel
and with the terry silver he said you
end up with a guy's blood on your shirt
that was obviously when he punched uh
that actor who he punched by the way his
name is gabe jared he was in the film
real genius 1985 with val kilmer i
actually met him he was the sign
interpreter for my best friend will so
fun fact there uh we also get the
amazing reference by johnny when he says
do you ever see the movie ladybugs 1992
directed by cindy j fury the guy who
directed johnny's favorite film iron
eagle just saying 1986.
also too he mentioned this guy who got
no respect what movie was william zapkin
in 1986 oh yeah my favorite one of my
favorite comedies back to school with
rodney dangerfield he was the bully of
jason mellon
why
yeah so that was really cool that he
mentioned about ronnie dangerfield when
they they shared a few scenes together
in that film if you have not seen that
movie please check it out also we got a
reference to back to school from one of
the previous seasons where they were
doing the dating profiles it's cavemen
are cool he dressed like a caveman for
halloween in that film so getting some
good back to school references here some
rodney dangerfield um but have you seen
that film ladybugs no
it was a good all right it's more of a
guilty pleasure but
it's an interesting film but i grew up
with that movie and i i i don't care how
bad it is i freaking love that movie and
rodney dangerfield is so funny and that
and
basically what uh johnny was talking
about he dressed up uh
god rest his soul jonathan brandeis who
almost got the role of uh
anakin skywalker lost out to hayden
christensen they're not losing yourself
right now
you're getting all it's got two
directions yeah but uh that was cool
that they mentioned that movie because i
grew up with that film so that was
really cool uh i've never seen ladybugs
referenced in anything so that was
really cool yeah that's amazing
that was fantastic andrew but i can't
help but notice
one specific thing in what you just said
is that
neither greg or i is your best friend
what's up what's a will
no i said one of my best friends
he said
you guys know what you said you guys
know all my best friends
we know will we met well twice
lovely guy was a great guy but uh yeah
this episode i feel like we need to just
keep on calling out things that we want
because then we'll get them in the next
episode
this is also like the hawk kind of
getting a little bit of a peel back at
least i mean i feel like dimitri did a
lot of lifting through that scene in
terms of he's the one trying to coax him
back into
having uh you know just back into being
in the spirit of
you know not being so uh
just broken up about everything yeah i
wouldn't have wanted more than one
episode of hawk being down on himself
i'm like no it's a necessary step
yeah but if it went on i'd be like come
on get let's get this going yeah i i we
know where it's going yeah but yeah
and i mean i hope that that at least
does
yes i don't expect it at this point but
you know i hope they at least keep the
sort of oh character beats open with him
especially i mean dimitri often is just
like comedic relief or whatever but i
like getting a little bit of character
on both of them because they are
prominent people who have stuck around
like it was cool to see aisha back but
like you know they're central
so uh well i think with uh dimitri i
that i really like to see him work a lot
here
i think like that he's a good actor good
after that kid he's got a hell of a kick
i know surprise i was like that was one
take right there that's an impressive
kick right there yeah that was like
perfectly eyelined with uh daniel
larusso i'm assuming his stunt double
but that was a great that was a
surprisingly
didn't look cgi
they spent all that money to get his
head on a stuntman's body no i'm talking
about the kick yeah yeah you could do
you could do like fake
you could do uh you can like yeah
yeah and yeah sometimes it just looks
awful uh yeah but that did not look fake
but but you know like he was really
establishing
you know his character arc throughout
the seasons and i was like yeah this
guy's grown a lot actually yeah i think
about it he's a lot more confident and i
like how he was embracing the position
he's in and he's a i have a feeling by
the time we get to the tournament he's
going to show up some skills that we
didn't think he really had it
which i really like hawk great stuff
and uh robbie
she's constantly showing up for like
five seconds for some reason i'm james
dean
six episodes in and robbie gets like 10
20 seconds straight but they're
impactful in 10 to 20 seconds yeah yeah
it was it was it was nice to see him and
daniel daniel to have that scene
together but the
the cobra cars man that liquor scene
that was really i think i think that's
the key to it is
it really clicked for me in that moment
is what's missing here is daniel needs
to accept the fact that he needs a
little bit of he has a little bit of
cobra kind him
and
maybe johnny desires a little bit of
miyagi dough in him you know and i'm not
gonna say if there is some miyaki doing
him but i think he's dis
i think he desires some of it yeah and a
little bit of that tranquility or peace
as well they are juggling a lot right
now
uh uh so far nothing's feeling like left
to them i always wait for like a full
like you said the whole thing with
let's just see what we want out there
and i'm sure the show will acknowledge
you to bring it back around in some way
so to to be doing that with
what's like i like that i like the
inclusion of this whole thing with the
find your female warrior
but i wonder what it's the tory stuff
that i find the most compelling
absolutely at the moment i really like
her a lot and
well i just read some comments that were
doing actually i hadn't read one comment
that gave me crap about it
i don't read the comments on this
because some of you guys are [ __ ]
and spoilers
every one of you is a bully out of this
yeah don't read the comments
that's just challenging us to fight
stones but i like the
i really like what they've set up here
and
i'm just waiting for them to get back
together because the the cobra kai and
miyagi do you know you know it's going
to happen yeah well i mean eagle thing
sorry yeah they got to come back
together and i think too one thing that
they've done nicely in this season as
well is
tempering the and balancing the drama
with the karate stuff because i feel
like you know all the seasons have a
pretty good consistency level in terms
of how broad or not they want to get and
how nuanced and whatever but i feel like
there were certain times where it's like
man there are just karate fights
breaking out everywhere just oh yeah
yeah yeah it feels a little
without feeling any less you know akin
to the height that the show has gone to
before and that is fitting for it it
also feels a little more grounded or a
little more
it's stretching the limits of my like
how are half of them not in jail right
now you know whereas other seasons have
gone you know kind of further out into
that territory
yeah that's true this is a good point
it's a little bit more just like
immediate drama within circles
and like there's it's because it still
feels like there's a lot of conflict and
a lot of moments of intensity and it's
more now of like it's a lot of just like
gonna
maybe but you know it seems like yeah
they're they're doing something a lot
more intricate and complicated even
though it has a lot of the same
satisfying elements that you know make
it so fun yeah it's a lot of intimate
debates and accusations about who the
other person really is not a perspective
it's a lot of blame happening here and a
lot of assumptions about here's who you
really are here's who you really are
right that's what a lot of them are
doing
uh it's interesting stuff
all right guys andrew do you have
anything more to add i just want to add
that that would be good it's very
[ __ ] it's going to be amazing now
it's just going to say the the scene
that you alluded to earlier with daniel
and terry that put such a smile on my
face i love seeing those two interact
with each other they've just got such a
chemistry uh and they work really well
together and i really really enjoyed
that again just the manipulation of
terry silva getting in daniel's head and
i mean but he did have a point where
he's got a little bit of cobra guy in
him and i just like the way they play
off of each other and uh yeah and he got
and we even got a danny boy call so that
that was that was the most important
thing
more important than any other
development yeah
all right guys well tell us your
thoughts down below did you actually
stick around for this portion are you
like what's the [ __ ] point the next
episode's out where's the next step all
the episodes around guys here's the next
episode why are you why are you wasting
time talking about each individual
episode just put out the reactions
call it a day don't appreciate all the
work and craftsmanship that went into
each individual episode
the fact that you know there are people
who like i wrote this one i really want
to do this this episode just throw it in
the big pile of episodes where you
forget which episodes what because you
didn't take time to appreciate it
individually just watch the whole thing
what are you doing yeah i get that i get
that we're wasting our time we're just
milking this is all we're doing
all right guys so we'll see you later
thanks for being here hey follow andrew
if you made it this far movie source
channel